I grew up on a family farm my family's
been farming for 130 years in southeast
Arkansas and I'm a fifth generation
farmer we raised cotton rice corn and
soybeans along with My Brother Sam our
extended families and a lot of great
co-workers could not do it without them
so when I was uh 16 years old I came
home from school one day it was my dad's
birthday my birthday was three days
later I expec in some type of party
event but my dad had just went through
the historic 1980 drought and when I got
home that day my mom was crying my dad
was trying to console
her and there's a foreclosure letter on
the
bar we thought we were going to lose the
Family Farm that we had had in our
family for
Generations luckily we did not lose the
farm and but he still struggled
financially when I was 22 years
old um after a little time in the Army I
decided I was going to start
farming so my brother and I rented a
farm my dad couldn't help us he didn't
have the finances he could not help us
get started farmer is a very Capital
intensive
business and so we got FHA beginning
farmer loan and let me tell you
something about renting a farm when
you're 22 years
old no one rents you a farm unless no
one else wants to rent
it it was a big piece of land it was
Cash rent I mean the the states were
set we were we were doomed to fail and
we weren't focused on environmental
sustainability back then we were focused
on economic sustainability how do we
make higher yield how do we use less
fertilizer how do we get to the next
year and feed our
family
and it happens that economic and
environmental sustainability go hand in
hand along with social sustainability as
we use less fertilizer use less water
our yields start going up it was just an
a great thing so one of the first things
we did did on our rice
fields we adopted a technique that's a
little different
we leveled our Fields completely flat
this is called zero grade rice all over
the world has grown in a flooded
environment
everywhere and most people use the
natural Contour of the earth to Cascade
the water down and let the water flow
downhill and they're always we call it
continuous flood they continuously put
water on their
fields and we leveled ours flat with a
perimeter r
Road and what that Perimeter Road lets
us do is capture rainfall so we're
actually pump less water W you're able
to use less water we have less runoff
less erosion less nutrients leaving our
field nothing leaves our field unless we
want it to
so I get around uh farmers and I tell
them about potential carbon credits and
other things and our family was um lucky
we were one of the first ever in the
world to agriculture carbon credits in
2016 to Microsoft using this uh protocol
that we've designed on rice and I got
that let me let me just back up a little
bit tell you how I got that I'm I'm not
I didn't get that on my own I met two
very instrumental people one was Dr Merl
Anders he is the uh world renown
greenhouse gas expert and he started
mentoring me the other was a buyer from
Mars foods and we were in a leadership
class class together and we started
talking and we started thinking about
sustainability so that's how my journey
started but you know when I tell other
Farmers that they could potentially sell
carbon credit they could help companies
reduce their scope 3 emissions they
could save money possibly enroll in um
environmental climate smart practices
for the government they say I'm just
trying to get by farming is a
generational business people have been
doing things passed down father to son
father to son and you'll see father to
daughter here in a minute it's passed
down
generational and we only get one chance
a year to make a mistake so when you
tell people about doing things that are
outside their Norm it scares the heck
out of them so I found a different way
of talking to them about it I say well
you know you could save $40 to $50 on
your pumping cost you could sell a
carbon credit you could get paid more by
a company for doing the right thing this
starts to Pete their interest risk
mitigation is how we're going to get
Farmers involved we are a for-profit
industry so they're not going to do
anything that they think hurts their
yields so
Jessica um went to college got a ad
Business Degree a sustainability minor
went on to get her MBA emphasis on
finance now she's back helping
me not all the time on the Family Farm
she works for dut unlimited one of the
most uh aggressive conservationists in
the rice industry they are an awesome
partner to work with she's back working
with dut unlimited but she's been
helping me with protocols and data
collection one of the things that I
wanted to figure out was number one
what's important how are we going to
quantify it and then how are we going to
sell that data cuz everyone here wants
to know can we have your data no you
can't
um
so anyway so we're trying to figure out
how to quantify that so we established
what is called the smart rice protocol
we partner with the global Seed Company
rice Tech and we had one of the first
ever there's a couple more I promise you
it's the most rigorous but we have one
of the first ever third-party verified
sustainable rice packages that hit the
market a few months ago and we're trying
to get in in retail locations and then
we're also helping some major re um end
users with their scope three and I think
that's going to be the future but
Jessica's role in growing rice is much
different than mine and she's part of
the Next Generation to come take over
our family
farm
I'm a sixth generation farmer growing up
I remember running around outside
barefoot catching as many snakes Turtles
frogs as possible and then trying to
convince my parents to let me keep them
inside as
pets eventually my dad bought me an
aquarium and we had fun with that for a
little while inside until a few of the
snakes got got lost in our house and we
never found them
sorry we live and work in southeast
Arkansas McGee specifically our town has
4,000 residents and one stoplight the
nearest airport Starbucks shopping mall
Whole Foods is 2 hours away in any
direction without places like this and
Farmers like us you'd be hungry naked
and
sober
I sometimes jokingly say that I have
three sometimes four full-time jobs but
I really have three or four full-time
jobs my day job is as a conservation
coordinator with Ducks Unlimited under
the rice stewardship partnership I work
alongside rice Farmers to protect
restore and manage Wetlands for
waterfoul
waterfoul spend a lot of time in rice
fields by the way I'm also a wife mother
and I do anything and everything I can
for our family farm the last one doesn't
pay the bills but it's hard to say no to
my dad so when he sent me an email about
a grant he was interested in a little
over a year ago I got to work my dad
releases the butterflies and I have to
catch them I have to figure out how to
do what's going on whatever is in his
mind he's The Thinker I'm the
doer this grant specifically was the
usda's Partnerships for climate smart
Commodities I submitted a proposal on
behalf of our farm and it was
successfully selected we are going to
work with farmers in southeast Arkansas
to educate them about the benefits of
growing sustainable rice we're going to
work with veterans immigrants limited
resource and socially disadvantaged
Farmers Farmers that aren't so different
from family just a few Generations ago
we will then Implement pay for practices
such as alternate weding and drying
cover crop no till and low teal we will
then help them learn about and document
their greenhouse gas benefit benefits
monitor measure report and verify them
then market and sell that rice at a
premium to help them realize the
benefits of producing sustainable rice
the economic Advantage I'm a farmer but
not in the way you might think I don't
drive the tractors and I don't plant the
rice but I know how to take what my dad
has learned and what he is doing and
share that with others I know how to
interpret the data and see the reduction
in inputs that has both an economic and
an environmental impact I don't know if
that alone is enough to stop climate
change but I'm surrounded by Farmers
that are doing everything they can to be
more
sustainable I think my brother and I
will take over the farm someday if my
dad lets us and hopefully um when my son
is old enough I'll take him out on the
farm and show him what I do I'll tell
him he can go do whatever he wants to do
and hopefully one day I'll see him back
on the farm the Seventh
Generation but for that to happen we
need a sustainable farming industry one
that rewards Trailblazers and early
adopters instead of penalizing them
Farmers like my family who are on the
front lines of sustainable rice
production so Jessica mentioned
alternate wedding and drying and I think
in my haste I left it out so let me tell
you what it is it is when we flood a
rice field continuously like my dad
taught us we put 4 Ines of water on it
we have a evaporation rate of about a/
quar inch a day so we have about 16 days
available water a rice is an anerobic
crop it's grown in flooded conditions
when the soil starts to dry the
microbial Community goes dormant and the
field stops emitting methane emissions
let me tell you why that's important
there are 400 million Acres of rice
grown globally it is the largest emitter
of methane gas that is the largest user
of irrigation water and our methods if
used can reduce greenhouse gas by 50%
reduce water use by 50% increase yields
to feed a hungry
world if our protocols were adopted more
widely can you imagine the
benefits if you take care of the planet
it will take care of you that's true for
farmers and for all of us Farmers take
care of consumers take care of all of
you every single day it's time for you
to start taking care of farmers thank
you thank
you